frieden kollegen wie die letzten beiden
wir müssen die letzten beiden warum
frieden
servus s kids und herzlich willkommen
zur dritten folge von roths top ten
und wie immer werden wir zu beginn einen
blick in die starts platz 83 deshalb
machte ist lange erreicht platz 80 auch
fast schon das heißt es muss eine
vorgekommen und ich würde sagen hier ist
die folge
wir schauen jetzt mal ehrlich es gibt
gespräche
wir werden bomber spielen hätte ich den
bomber gewünscht ich poste jetzt die
kommentare bzw sich post keine
kommentare sondern packt ihr euch das
video natürlich seien wir sehen das
gleiche video wieder bislang so da sind
wir da die runde geht in zehn sekunden
los ich zum heute mal alleine schreibt
mir die kommentare was ihr davon haltet
ob ich lieber alleine spielen sein oder
doch lieber mit dem platz zusammen zieht
zusammen zocken soll weil man sich dann
doch auf die aufnahme konzentrieren muss
man ist halt so dass in den fans wird es
ein bisschen bisschen ruhiger aber man
kann auch einfach mal entspannt so die
sachen ansprechen die emser auf dem
herzen liegen das bisschen
ausdiskutieren
das scheint ja momentan sowieso recht
beliebt zu sein dass man sich einfach
mal hinsetzt und einfach so redet gibt
es beispielsweise von broken festes
format late night oder rede macht das
jetzt auch es ist eigentlich ganz cool
und ich mag es natürlich in form einer
klassischen road to top ten runder
beziehungsweise klassisch noch nicht
ganz aber wir sind immerhin schon bei
der dritten folge und damit platz 85
die kiste ist garantiert - mal rein ich
habe aber schon nicht wenn wir die
packen die sport aber es ist auch ein
bisschen kaka mit equipment werden
es hat sich verdoppelt einfach
immer der person so seltsame sachen geil
geil war das echt traumhaft borutta ich
fasse es nicht fast mein glück nicht
weil er nicht selber 20 bürger entfernt
das nicht sogar müssen jetzt bisschen
raum verschaffen und dann jetzt sechs
achs bikram yoga kom kom kom geraden
schnell gehen soll per klick ich mich
wieder letzten uhr
aber ich kanns echt richtig schön viel
machen das passt alles perfekt sagt zack
zack
so haben wir das schwert jetzt gibt es
kollege jetzt gibt es brennt natürlich
weg dieser springt weg weil ein känguru
ist können wir jetzt nicht so viel
machen leider springt ins wasser da oder
wohin geht dessen kollege wohin gehst du
komm doch mal her komm doch mal her
ich will nur spielen so jetzt jetzt geht
auf uns drauf warum auch immer jetzt ich
verstehe es nicht
darauf bin ich vorbereitet hast du das
gedacht egal ob das mal den hintern und
er würde auch ein bisschen abstand
gewinnen das ist doch ärgerlich
mensch da stecken wir jetzt die hits ein
wir stecken die hits ein und werden dann
einfach ist das ist echt kacke das ist
so als würde man für etwas bezahlen dann
kriegt sie andere hat ist nicht geil da
dies nicht falsch ich gar keinen fall
wird mir nicht gut
jetzt aber ohne rac noch dinge dar auf
pump apa
den treffer gut er hatte den rangers war
das knapp war das knapp bisher zach du
scheiße und der nächste gegner bitte wir
dürfen jetzt nicht so gut wenn das
irgendwo irgendwann auffallen und direkt
dahinter konnten wir wegmüssen realms
oder das ist eine farce mache ich glück
gehabt alter richtig glück gehabt dass
jetzt gerade switched wurden korrekt mit
ihren fans erstmal die leggins machen
erstmal durch jahre alter das war gerade
eben mal richtig stressig es war ist
halt die sache es ist immer ein extremes
risiko und low life auf den gegner
zugehen wenn gut erwischt so auch der
einzige grund warum ich das überlebt
haben die hatten ja glaubt die hälfte
der herzen oder so und er denn die
erschwerten dem wir uns gut gehütet hat
und so was ist mit dem was der kollege
hat ist mit der kollege auf etwas auf
einer ist er da lag doch nicht so ist
ich fass es nicht
ich fasse es nicht dass es so nervig
sondern messen denn hiermit war
jetzt gehen wir einfach noch so eine
waffe water fakt aber irgendwie das
gefühl dass das die dass die
bombenexplosion einfach noch extrem
wenig schaden machen was komplett
nutzlos geworden sind jetzt gesehen
der stand direkt linie als explodiert
ist und wir mussten noch zwei hier zum
dia schwert geben
das heißt dort extrem wenig leben
verloren das kann auch nicht dass in der
sache seiner besuchst gefühl irgendwie
ach nee betreffen so gar nicht klappen
bösen tritt gegeben mir jetzt nicht so
gehst du tust du meine gegner stellen
kommen welches auto man so zac jetzt
haben wir wie ein irrer um herumgelaufen
darin bieten april der kommission opel
machen wenn der mal zukunft kommt sehr
gut auf dem tape ja weiter bogen
brauchen wir nicht brauchen wir nicht
für mich zum enden wie sein wie eine
gold april alter alle scheiße
weiter gehts jetzt wir machen halt
einfach so eine kleine schnittwunde will
ich sagen schauen einfach mal dass wir
heute mal alles einfach alles souverän
aus dem weg schnetzeln moment mal musste
gegner teilweise hat man das so dass der
kompost irgendwie so sich so raunt
breiter po einmal aufschub trenker stadt
renker danquart verband getroffen
kollege er hat mich nicht getan hat dann
auch welche die nehme ich natürlich sehr
gerne mit mir was heißt in dem spiel bin
ich behindert
die nehme ich mit weil diese tränke doch
noch ziemlich ziemlich lustig sind etwas
abwechslung weil ich mag ja wirklich
noch nie gespielt hat kein einziges mal
und andererseits machen die das spiel
ein bisschen variantenreicher wir haben
einmal regeneration zwei und einmal als
fitness also speed 2 das nervt ihn
jetzt rennt erweckt hat einen dia
busfahrt und rennt weg ich fass es nicht
komm schon alter wilo kann man denn sein
oder so wieder abschalten alter das hat
immer die miese diese bilder und taktik
acom pläne
panik aber das war geil alter in er mit
erkenne was mit mit mit er hat es
gesehen
er ist auf uns zu gesprungen und wir
haben ihn mit er erledigt wir brauchen
mehr gewicht bekommen
das verstehe ich jetzt nicht wir sind
wir gar doris bekommen bei dem kiel
seine besondere fähigkeit es müsste doch
eigentlich wissen dass das nicht geht
die fähigkeit hat ich stehe voll auf dem
schlauch wer ihr könnt ja in die
kommentare schreiben woran das gerade
lag ich ja gar keine peilung 00 uhr
ahnung alle machen es einfach mal mit
dir leggins eleganz ist
geldverschwendung leggins bringt auch
nicht mehr als gut also im vergleich zum
fahrrad also zu allen längen übrigens
auch noch nen halben mehr und verbraucht
diaz ist das letzte was ich mache da
warte ich die börse noch zwei weitere
die us kriege da kann ich mir noch ein
helm machen
ich weiß nicht mehr weiter geht
frieden kollegen die letzten beide
wissen die letzten beiden machen frieden
mit 1 5 also ich war mir 50
ich bin ein vollhorst die kann man nicht
in fünf modus gehen so kollege tchibo
wissen wer das abo ist und du weißt wie
die hits kassiert nämlich nur selbst
das war's mit ihm und wir haben die
runde gewonnen ich schaue gerade mal je
auf jeden fall ja dann schreiben ist
eben aus meine freese meine friese wir
sind bei neun minuten das ist eine
souveräne dauer würde ich sagen wenn es
euch gefallen hat dann lasst einen
daumen nach oben da wie gesagt schreibt
in die kommentare bock habt dass ich mir
irgendwann aufnehme oder ob ich lieber
alleine aufnehme das auch ein wichtiges
feedback für mich da manchmal so sehen
kann was ihr am liebsten habt ansonsten
in die kommentare schreiben welches kind
ihr als nächstes sehen wollt wir hatten
jetzt bomber in dieser folge in der
vorherigen folge hatten wir den more fun
den ersten folge dass familien
falls die drei kids in erstmal raus alle
anderen können sich immer noch gewünscht
werden und da würde ich sagen wir sehen
uns im nächsten video wieder macht's gut